bonsoir au lac ramolli merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france tout
d'abord une première réaction à ce
rapport bonsoir j'ai juste une petite
précision je suis en mer et l'air et non
pas dvd donc concernant ce rapport qui a
été établi par mail sur la gestion de la
crise sanitaire par le gouvernement en
tant que maire tous les maires ont eu à
subir un peu ce pilotage un petit peu à
l'instrument ou sans instrument où on
pourra dire parce que les consignes de
l'état n'était pas forcément hyper clair
ni pour la population ni pour les
collectivités territoriales pour moi
pour l'autorité territoriale que nous
mais ne représentons et là dessus nous
avons dû faire face à des 10 des
annonces gouvernementales sur sur les
chaînes de télé une interprétation
ensuite faite par le premier ministre
dans les différents conférence de presse
qu'il a pu donner et enfin les
circulaire préfectorale qui n'avaient
pas forcément toujours dans le sens de
ce qui est annoncé par l'état et ça
c'est la même chose depuis le mois de
mars
jusqu'aujourd'hui les connectivités on
va faire face à une crise qui tu es ma
chère pour notre population majeure pour
notre pays même majeurs au niveau
international avec les moyens qui sont
les nôtres en essayant de respecter tant
que possible les consignes qui sont
données par le gouvernement
et lorsque nous étions pas d'accord ici
le choix que nous avions fait au niveau
du territoire grand paris grand test
lorsque nous étions pas d'accord avec
les directions prises par le
gouvernement plutôt que de prendre des
arrêtés qui irait à l'encontre des
décisions du gouvernement et y rendre
population dans une m notre population
de ne faire d'incertitude et illégalité
nous avons fait le choix plusieurs
collègues et moi même de poursuivre les
différents arrêtés lorsque nous
désignons qui avait des failles sur ces
arrêtés et que ces arrêtés créer une
inéquité face aux services publics
alors les verdicts effectivement on le
disait et c'est vers la france était mal
armé face à la pandémie son estimation
du risque épidémique c'est un diagnostic
que vous mr lr vous partagez je le
partage totalement effectivement la
france tu étais était ma d'armé après à
la décharge du gouvernement il faut
aussi avoir pleinement conscience que
cette crise majeure était aussi inédite
inédite et le aucun gouvernement dans le
monde n'aurait pu anticiper cette cette
crise
ensuite nous avons deux phases de dépit
des missions sur le coronavirus celle de
deux femmes auraient pu nous servir de
leçon dès la première phase nous aurons
plus de tirs et les délais sont
extrêmement concrètes sur la façon de
gérer la deuxième de la seconde phase
qui allait arriver qui était déjà prévu
qui était déjà prévue dès le
dès la fin de la première phase on
savait déjà que nenê tente pas du tout à
l'abri d'un dans le confinement et de
nouveaux pics épidémiques
alors les membres l ère de la commission
se sont eux abstenus de voter un
contrairement aux républicains vous
faites partie veuillez nous excuser les
airs pour cette erreur de présentation
vous comprenez leur réaction aux députés
la reine qui soutient évidemment
l'exécutif bat ces députés sont pris
entre entre deux feux ils ont pleinement
conscience que tout n'a pas été fait
strictement comme il devait être fait et
comme je disais tout à l'heure je ne
suis pas là pour taper sur le
gouvernement le gouvernement a fait ce
qu'il a pu avec les moyens qu'ils
avaient ils auraient pu faire certains
autres choix et c'est là dessus que je
ne comprends pas la réaction de certains
députés et les relais qui aurait pu
faire preuve de pragmatisme et se tire
des effectivement en toute humilité nous
aurions pu faire différemment sur
certains points et admettre cela ne pas
l'admettre ne pas le voter juste
s'abstenir et se dire finalement bas
c'est très bien comme ça non cela ne
convient pas à la population cela nous
convient pas et là dessus heureusement
que dans notre pays nous sommes une
vraie démocratie que les groupes
d'opposition au niveau de l'assemblée
nationale ont pu faire valoir leur droit
de parole sur la gestion qui a été faite
par le gouvernement alors un effet du du
good grand paris et grand test dont vous
faites partie vous aussi ont décidé
d'attaquer en justice le décret sur la
fermeture des bars et des restaurants
pour quelles raisons pas exactement les
mêmes raisons que nous avions attaqué
également le premier décret qui
interdisait les commerces non essentiels
de
d'ouvrir le gouvernement partait du
principe que certains commerçants ne
pouvait pas vrai parce que il ne
pourrait pas assurer la sécurité
sanitaire de leurs clients dans leurs
établissements alors que justement dans
ces petits commerces
les gérants de ces commerces avaient
pris toutes les mesures nécessaires au
même titre que les restaurateurs
aujourd'hui les restaurateurs
aujourd'hui sont vraiment les laissés
pour compte de cette gestion de crise
parce que avant de demander aux
restaurateurs de fermer le gouvernement
leur a demandé de faire de prendre tout
un tas de mesure d'investir pour pouvoir
assurer la sécurité sanitaire à rendre
dans un délai extrêmement court à partir
de telle date vous avez fermé lui fermer
les restaurants pour pour moi il y à un
manque de logique austry aussi dans tout
cela parce que les différents
restaurants d'entreprise les différents
restaurants scolaires qui existe dans
mon établissement scolaire dans les
collèges dans les lycées restaurer la
population doit quand même pouvoir
continuer à se nourrir et les risques
que le gouvernement montre en avant pour
fermer les restaurants existe tout
autant dans les restaurants
d'entreprises dans les restaurants
scolaires
non vous savez aussi pardonnez moi mais
vous savez aussi que voilà les comptines
dans les entreprises sont plutôt réduit
vous savez bien que ça on brasse voilà
des gens dans un restaurant notamment
vous contestez cette dangerosité
je ne conteste pas cette dangerosité
parce que je ne suis pas médecin je sais
rester à ma place lorsqu'il le faut je
demande simplement au conseil d'état au
même titre que mes collègues de
réanalyser ce décret pour voir si ce
décret ne crée pas une rupture d'équité
face
à la liberté d'entreprendre des avis des
restaurateurs merci en tout cas
rollin crasnault lhimer l air de gagny
merci d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france